Oh yeah,
yeah, converted made when the presidency
very
great.
Okay,
no.
Your election in
Yeah, I know, right?
Hey, there he is. I see him.
I know. I know.
There we go. There we go. Come on.
Why are you waiting?
Look at those.
I mean, they've been, like, right here the whole game.
Yeah, yeah.
Get the ball out.
They're not going for it.
They're attacking the guy with the ball.
Get the ball, boys.
All right.
There you go.
Nice job, guys.
Good counter.
Let's go, Prebs!
This is the first time they've been over halfway since we got here.
I feel like I'm hurting over here.
Way to go, Jays!
All right.
Is this good again?
It takes.
There we go.
Nobody's there.
Way to go, 15!
Way to go!
There you go.
There you go, boys.
Go, boys, boys!